Robert Warren, you're on stage going
once.
>> Yes, sir. How you doing today?
>> I'm good. You're a Muslim?
>> Yes, I am.
>> All right. What message did Paul
corrupt? I
>> think he corrupted the uh in the book of
Acts. I think it talks about
circumcision where he makes it kind of
all right where you don't have to be
circumcised. And I think that's kind of
like the covenant, the first covenant
that's in the Old Testament of
circumcision. I think he corrupted that.
I think he corrupted the hero, oh
Israel, your Lord God is one. I think he
made God into that triune God that you
worship now. Uh I think he corrupted uh
that you know the children of Israel
that Israel is God's chosen people. I
think he made it where, you know, the
covenant was like with not just Israel,
with the Gentiles, too, because he
mostly went to the Gentiles. And um and
he was preaching, you know, the law, but
he was, you know, corrupting it, though.
I think some of it came off of what
Jesus taught also. I mean, Jesus kind of
I think that's one of the reasons why
they wanted to kill Jesus is because
some of the things like the sword you
read earlier when when it states that
Jesus came to make lawful, some of the
things that was unlawful, you know,
that's that's probably true in a sense
that, you know, some of the things that,
you know, the children of Israel
believed, you know, that they believed
that was part of the law. It says of the
Torah. It says of the Torah.
>> Excuse me.
>> It says of the Torah.
>> It says in the Torah.
>> Yeah. It says, "I I came confirming that
which was before me in the Torah and to
make lawful some of that which was
forbidden."
>> Right. So some of the things that were
forbidden to the children of Israel
became lawful. Like you know, I mean,
not being able to marry like
>> he's changing the Torah. He's changing
the Torah according to the Quran. The
laws of the Torah. No, he's not changing
the Torah. He's just making certain
things that was unlawful to the children
of Israel.
>> Where where were where where were these
laws found?
>> Where were the laws found? I mean, if
you read the you read the Torah, the
laws are in there, the laws of Moses.
>> So, if he's So, if he's making things
lawful that was unlawful, then he's
changing the Torah, right? He's changing
the laws that's in the Torah. He's
making some of the laws, some of the
things that what they thought to be
unlawful, God is saying to them now that
you know the Jesus came with the message
of whosoever believes. It's not just
>> so he changed so he so he changed the
law right
>> I mean far as the children of Israel
were concerned only the prophets were
for them that's why Jesus curses the
women woman and say that you know and
call her a dog
>> say you know I only come for the lost
sheep of the children of Israel
>> brother brother Rob
>> what was my question
>> so I'm not yeah what was your question
again because I think I think I kind of
asked
>> next toothpaste How you doing?
>> Hello. Salam alaykum.
>> Salam.
>> Yeah. So, I found the injeil. You've
been asking where is the inje right?
>> Yeah. I've been asking what is it
actually? Not where is it.
>> So, you're what's the inje? Yeah. What's
the angel? I found what's the inje? It's
not the Bible that you got. Okay. So, if
you read Matthew 4:23,
>> it talks about the inil. You know what
it says?
>> Before you before you go, let me just uh
make sure we we do this right. Okay. I
can't hear you. Still breathing.
>> Can you hear me? Testing. Testing.
Testing.
>> Okay. Okay. Good.
>> Just hold on a second. We got to make
sure we do this right. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> What's going on everybody? I am your
host God Logic and we are back with
another segment of What's the Ingill? We
have our new contestant who goes by the
nickname stage name toothpaste cuz he
going to clean you out. Toothpaste. You
know what the angel is? Go ahead and
tell us what it is, brother.
>> Yeah. So, in the Bible, if you read
Matthew 4:23, it mentions what is the
angel. It actually tells you.
>> Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So, it says Jesus went about all
Galilee, teaching, preaching the gospel
of the kingdom. That's the angel.
>> I'm sorry. Where was he at?
>> What? Matthew 4:23.
>> No, no, I know the verse, but where did
it say Jesus was preaching at?
>> Galilei.
>> Okay. Nice. All right. All right. Good.
Okay. All right.
>> Gospel of the kingdom. That's the deal.
Gospel of the kingdom. Not the gospel of
John. Not the gospel of Matthew.
Separate.
>> Okay. Okay. So, what And what was that
Gospel of the kingdom? Where can where
where can we find it? Is it is it
>> the one that's Yeah. That what Jesus
preached. It's not from your Bible.
>> Wait. So, you went to the Bible to
identify what the angel was. The Bible
is a hadith of Jesus, right?
>> Okay. So the Bible tells you what the
angel was.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So Bible is the hadith. Like
for example, we got hadits. It tells you
about the Quran that Prophet Muhammad
was. Yeah.
>> I got you. I got you. So I I got you. So
since the Bible tells us Since the Bible
tells us what the NGL is.
>> I like I like what you're doing. Can you
go to Mark chapter 1?
>> Okay. Hold on.
>> Okay.
>> Mark 1
>> verse one.
>> Verse one. Okay. John the Baptist. The
>> Mark 1 verse one. beginning of the good
news about Jesus the Messiah, the son of
God.
>> Right. Yeah. So, right there it said
Mark says that this is the beginning of
the gospel of Jesus. Right.
>> No, it says the beginning of the good
news. Oh, hold on. I have a wrong Hold
on. Give me a moment. I have the wrong
translation.
>> It's okay. Take your time.
>> Yeah. Uh, let me I had the King James.
>> That's all right.
>> I think that's the most accurate. Okay.
The beginning of the gospel of Jesus
Christ. It's not saying gospel of
kingdom.
>> Well, the gospel of Jesus is the gospel
of the kingdom. It's the same thing,
right?
>> So, where is the gospel of Jesus then?
What is the gospel of Jesus?
>> We're reading it. We're reading it. Mark
1:1 says, "This is the beginning of the
gospel of Jesus Christ, the son of God."
And then he begins to write. So, this is
the gospel. Behold, I send my messenger
before your face, who will prepare your
way before you, the voice of one crying
in the wilderness, prepare the way of
the Lord, make his path straight. That's
the gospel of Jesus.
>> Yep. All of this is the gospel. All of
this is the gospel.
>> So Jesus is Jesus is telling you to
prepare the way for Prophet Muhammad,
right?
>> Jesus says Muhammad.
>> No, it says prepare the way of the Lord.
You think Muhammad's the Lord
>> in in the Bible sense? Yeah. Because
there are so many people referred to as
Lord, right? Even
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
>> Yeah.
>> You're saying that Muhammad is the Lord
that that has his way prepared for.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, the Lord is David is
called the Lord, right?
>> No, he's not.
>> Hold. I have to teach you guys your
Bible. Lord, okay. Title.
>> Do you know what? Do you know what this
is called? Do you know what this is
quoting?
>> Excuse me.
>> Do you know what the verse is quoting in
Mark 1:3? Do you know what it's called?
>> It's quoting the Jesus, the gospel of
Jesus Christ. Right.
>> Yeah. But it's referring to a particular
passage in the Old Testament. Do you
know what that passage is?
>> What?
>> It's Isaiah 40. Go to Isaiah 40 verse
three.
>> Isaiah 40
>> verse three.
>> Three. A voice of one calling in the So
Isaiah is is like uh prophesizing.
>> Isaiah is prophesying. That's right.
>> Of like what? Prophet Muhammad. Hold on.
>> No, he just said of Jesus. That's what
Mark says.
>> And this Isaiah is prophesying the Lord.
Prophesying God of read it.
>> The voice of one crying in the
wilderness prepared the way for the
Lord.
>> Finish it. Make straight in the desert a
highway for our god.
>> So the Lord is God that is how having
his way prepared, right?
>> All right. You can you can take the next
person.
>> Okay. Thank you.
Oh man.
>> Hello.
>> Hello, Muhammad.
>> Hello. I was I just want to ask like
contradiction in the Bible like in the
book of Matthew.
>> Okay. Before you do that,
>> yes.
>> What message did Paul corrupt?
>> Most of it, I guess.
>> All right. What was that? Well, I don't
know for sure, but I know like he
corrupted some parts of the New Bible,
of the New Testament.
>> Okay. So, the New Testament is the
message of Jesus.
>> Well, no, because the New Testament has
been corrupted over time.
>> And who corrupted it?
>> Well, Paul, I guess like most
>> So, the New Testament is the message of
Jesus and Paul corrupted it, right?
>> Well, yeah.
>> Okay. So, um can you give me an example
of what Paul corrupted exactly? Well, as
he says like in fourth Corinthians,
right? He says that the humans, right,
are the true church of God, but
according to the church fathers, the
Eastern Orthodox or like the Catholic
Church are the true church.
>> Where where does the New Testament say
that the Catholic Church or anything
like that is any true church or whatever
church?
>> Well, it doesn't, but according to the
church,
>> I asked you specifically, what does Paul
corrupt? I ask you what is a an example
of what Paul corrupted of the New
Testament of the message of Jesus?
>> I don't know for sure but I came here
like to ask you one thing about like
>> you don't know for sure.
>> Yeah.
>> So then how do you know that Paul
corrupted the New Testament when you
don't know for sure what he corrupted?
>> Well, I guess I don't know but like some
part of like the shakes like know better
than me.
>> Okay. So So basically you don't know
what Paul corrupted yet you're accusing
him of corrupting the New Testament.
Well, I guess because most of the like
said this.
>> Do you see how do you see how like silly
that sounds, bro?
>> I know, bro.
>> So, like for example, if I said um uh
Usman corrupted the Quran and what would
you ask me after that?
>> Well, what corrupted
>> exactly? What was corrupted?
>> And I say, uh, I don't know exactly, but
you know.
>> Yeah, it sounds silly, I guess.
>> So, does it sound silly when you say
Paul corrupted the New Testament, but
you don't know what he corrupted? Well,
in a case. Yeah. It sounds silly, I
guess.
>> So, then you should drop that argument,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> But I told you this like uh I want like
to know about like a contradiction from
the book of Matthew.
>> That's fine. We could get to that when
when our subject is done. When our
subject is done. I I'm glad that you're
being honest and you're admitting. So,
this is a silly position to have.
>> I'm honest.
>> Good. I hope so. This is a this is a
silly position to have that the New
Testament is corrupted if you don't know
what was corrupted, right?
>> Yep.
>> So then we can say that we can say the
New Testament was not corrupted then,
right?
>> Well, we can say but you said it was
corrupted, you know, like in a case.
>> You said I said that.
>> No, but like most of the shakes like
said that and I guess
>> no shake no shake says that or are you
talking about Islamic shakes? Yeah, but
I guess yeah, in a case I make the claim
that it was corrupted in a case, but I
don't know what is it fully because I
trust like the most of the shakes, but I
need like to get informed about this.
>> So, so you can't So, at least at least
for now, you can't hold that the New
Testament is corrupted, right? Cuz
>> you don't know.
>> Yeah, I guess. But still, I didn't want
to make the argument about like Paul
like corrupting.
>> Well, that's that's what the topic is
about.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you came in here with your own
topic, but my I have a topic already.
>> No.
But still the book of Matthew has seal
it stone corruptions. That's what I want
to like to ask you.
>> It has a corruption.
>> Yeah. Like
well contradiction is not a corruption.
You if you say corruption you're talking
the text. Hold on.
>> One second. You're talking over me for I
don't know what's happening right now.
>> I'm sorry.
>> But you're saying if you're talking
corruption, you're talking about
something that has to do with the text.
something that was either added or take
away taken away that distorts the
message and theme of of what is being
said of the context. That's what a
corruption is. So if you don't know what
has been corrupted, then you can't say
that there was a corruption, right?
>> I guess
>> so the Muslim contradiction.
>> So you and Muslims should stop saying
that the New Testament is corrupted,
right? If you don't have any evidence or
anything to compare to to say, "Oh yeah,
this was corrupted. This was corrupted."
You should just stop saying that alto
together. Right.
>> Well, yeah. But I have a piece of ev
evidence right here like
>> like of the Bible has been like has
contradictions.
>> So is it are we talking about
corruptions or are we talking about
contradictions?
>> We have a contra contradiction about
Judas.
>> Yeah. Are we talking about
contradictions or are we talking about
corruption man?
>> Well corruption the topic is about
corruption but I don't know. I just want
to like to know this thing about the
book of Matthew.
>> Okay. So if you want to know about the
book of Matthew, go ahead and search it
up, brother. Help you out.
>> Man, you guys are can't be serious.
Matty J. Ali, are you a Muslim?
>> Salam.
>> So, as I put it in the chat, um I
mentioned the contradictions just so we
can make sure we stay on point unlike
the other brothers that have been on
this on this stage.
>> Nice. So, what what message do you
believe Paul corrupted?
>> I'll choose the verse, the two verses.
I'll use Matthew 6:14. I'll read it.
Jesus said, "Forgive others and your
father will forgive you." He never
directly taught that his death will
atone for humanity sins. While Paul said
in Romans, "While we were still sinners,
Christ died for us. In him, we have
redemption through his blood, the
forgiveness of sins." Ephesians 17. So,
the contradiction to lamb Jesus taught
direct forgiveness through repentance.
Paul introduced blood sacrifice
theology.
>> Okay, I got you. And you're a Muslim,
right?
>> That doesn't answer my question. I just
need a simple yes or no will suffice.
>> Yes.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> All right. So you are a Muslim. All
right. So So basically from what I
gathered from you, you quoted Matthew
chapter 6. So you're saying that we can
find so the message of Jesus in the
writings of Matthew, right? Hello.
>> Correct. Correct.
>> Correct. Okay. So I want to you to do me
a favor. Well, actually I'll do it for
us. Okay. I'm going to pull up Matthew
chapter 26 and I'm going to pull up
verse 26. the 28
>> Passover.
>> Yep. Can you see the screen?
>> I'm very familiar with it.
>> All right. So, it says here, "Now as
they were eating, Jesus took bread and
after blessing it, broke it and gave it
to the disciples and said, "Take, eat.
This is my body." And he took a cup and
when he had given thanks, he gave it to
them, saying, "Drink of it all of you,
for this is my blood of the covenant
which is poured out for many for the
forgiveness of sins." So according to
this verse, does Jesus teach that it is
his blood that offers the forgiveness of
sins?
>> I would agree. Yes.
>> So it sounds like Paul is in line with
what Jesus said, right?
>> I would say in the sense of celebrating
the Passover, Christians don't celebrate
the Passover. They celebrate communion.
They
>> I'm not talking about Christians. I'm
talking about what Paul said. According
to the verse that you quoted from Paul
teaching that salvation is through the
blood of Jesus Christ, Jesus also
teaches the same thing. Right.
>> Correct. I agree.
>> Okay. Does Muhammad teach this?
>> No. We don't celebrate the Passover.
>> You don't celebrate the Passover. Nor do
you believe that it's by the blood of
Jesus that sins are forgiven. Right.
>> Nor do you. Correct.
>> Well, I do. I believe this. I believe
here what Jesus said. So, with that
being said, just hold on a second. So,
so with that being said, with that being
said, Muhammad contradicts the message
of Jesus here. Right. My response to you
is the fact that you yourself don't keep
the Passover is the understanding of my
my point, the contradiction.
>> That's cool and all. Does Muhammad
contradict Jesus when Jesus says that
it's his blood that's poured out for the
forgiveness of sins? Does Muhammad
contradict that?
>> All right. Respectfully, you said stay
on the topic of Paul corrupting the
Bible the same way that you
>> Thanks for coming. That's how easily you
tie up these Muslims, these mutons,
these Muhammadan. That's how easy it is,
ladies and gents. Musling. Musling the
Muslim. How you doing?
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> Awesome. What message do you believe
Paul corrupted?
>> I believe that he corrupts the the
crucifixion.
>> You believe that he corrupts the
crucifixion?
>> Correct. Yes.
>> Where can we find the original message
of the crucifixion?
>> Yeah. Inside of the Quran or inside of
our scripture? Like we can even appeal
to hadith if you want to. I don't mind.
>> So before the Quran. Is this is this
Omar? Oh, this is Cade. What are you
doing here, Kade?
>> What's good, bro?
>> What are you doing here?
>> What do you mean?
>> Isn't it haram to talk to me and be on
my panel?
>> What are you talking about?
>> What do you mean, what am I talking
about?
>> Yeah, what are you talking about?
>> Didn't you say it's haram to talk to me?
>> I think maybe you're confusing me with
somebody else or are you okay?
>> Are you're not on Tik Tok?
>> No, I'm not on Tik Tok. I just seen you
on my on my YouTube feed.
>> Okay. All right. My apologies. I confuse
you with another guy who goes by Cade.
And
>> why why does I Does that cook you or
something? Like, are you like friend?
I'm not too sure. What' you say?
>> Yeah. Are you like frightened of him or
something? Like I was kind of confused.
I don't really understand.
>> You didn't you you didn't hear what I
was accusing you of?
>> No. I I heard what you accused me of.
I'm like wondering why you're
>> If you If you heard If you heard what I
was accusing him of, when what what do
you not get? Are you you slow? You get
>> Yeah, cuz cuz Yeah, I'm telling you.
Because it's not me.
>> So if I know So you said that it's not
you. I apologize for thinking you were
him who said it was haram to talk to me.
So it wouldn't it wouldn't make sense if
you were him to come up and talk to me
if you said that it's not halal to talk
to me. So which prompts my question,
what are you doing here? Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah, sure. But that was it's not me. So
let's continue.
>> Okay. Not you.
>> Sure. Yeah. So what's uh
>> So you're saying the original message of
the crucifixion is found in the Quran?
>> Yes. Correct. There's I'll take the
position that Yeah. I'll tell you. So
>> wait, just be clear. There was no
message of the crucifixion before the
Quran.
>> Can I tell you?
>> Yes, please.
>> So yeah, it identifies in the Quran, but
the crucifixion like like the message in
accordance I was earlier.
>> No. Can I speak?
>> You wasn't here earlier. Audience, is
this the same guy?
>> Is your chat saying that or something?
>> You you certainly sound familiar. Hey
guys, is this is this the same guy uh
from earlier? Y'all let me know if y'all
recognize him.
>> Maybe we might be confusing with
somebody else. I'm not too sure. You
sound just like the other guy that I
that I bounced out. You argue just like
him. Your your cadence is just like his.
>> Interesting. I mean, like we must just
be like the exact same, you know? Like
must be like just really good at
debating.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah, it is you. It is.
>> It's not me. What you talking? It's not
even I'm I'm with you. I'm like a
different person.
>> Oh, yeah. Okay. All right.
>> Can we continue?
>> I'll put you back in the pot again. No
worries.
>> Can I Can I tell you? Is it okay?
>> Yeah. You're about to tell me how the
Quran is the only message that ever had
the message of the crucifixion. Go
ahead.
>> Correct. Yes, that's correct.
>> I'm going I'm going I'm going to take
the position that the the true uh
message when it comes to the crucifixion
was that simply it was something which
was made to appear so up to the people
meaning it was actually an important
event and the atonement for sin which
Paul speaks about is complete incorrect
and like contradicts the Quran. If I
establish that the Quran is simply like
I become a criterion. You got to say
that again.
>> I was no I was I was gonna say Muim. I
was gonna say Muay.
>> Oh, you changed the word this time, huh?
>> I'm feeling now. Wait, can I ask a quick
question?
>> At first, you were talking about the
criteria and earlier now.
>> Wait, how? Wait, just Yeah. One second.
Why did you drop me? Sorry. Before I
just
>> I thought I thought it wasn't you.
>> Yeah, I was joking. I was joking. Wait,
but why did you No, you wasn't joking.
You were lying. It was
>> No, I was Well, I was joking. I thought
you were joking.
>> You were lying. You were lying.
>> Well, I was I was joking.
>> Okay.
>> Wait, can can I continue though? Is it
okay? Are you just going to drop me?
Yeah, I'm I'm going to drop you. When
you showed to be a liar, you're a waste
of my time. You're a liar. You came up
and swore up and down that it wasn't
you, and now you're admitting that it
was you because I caught you. Muslims,
man, lie for the sake of Allah. It's
allowed. It's halal. It is halal to lie
for the sake of Allah.